قالت القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه ان
ضباطا كبارا في الجيش الاسرائيلي قدموا
توصيه لرئيس هيئه الاركان هيرسي هاليفي
لوقف حمله التشويه الواسعه ضد وكاله
الاونروا ونصح الضباط بعدم توسيع نطاق
تشويه الوكاله في الظروف الراهنه خصوصا
قبل المناقشه المزمع بالكونغرس الامريكي
وكذلك المستوى السياسي باسرائيل لتقرير
اليات التعامل مع الوكاله وايجاد بدائل
لها واشاروا الى ان تسريبات بشان الوكاله
والتي دفعت دولا لوقف تمويلها لم تكن
تسريبات اسرائيليه منظمه وحسب القناه يخشى
الضباط من ان تاتي عمليه تشويه الاونروا
قبل ايجاد بديل لها بنتائج سلبيه جدا في
قطاع
غزه حذر رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني
خلال لقائه في نيويورك مع الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو جوتيريش حذر من
التداعيات الكارثيه لوقف تمويل الاونروا
ودعا الى الفصل بين الوكاله كمؤسسه امميه
ذات قيم راسخه وبين الادعاءات بشان عدد من
موظفيها يخضعون للتحقيق واشارت الخارجيه
القطريه الى ان رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري والامين العام للامم
المتحده ناقشا اخر المستجدات في الشرق
الاوسط لا سما في قطاع غزه والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله كما ناقش سبل استمرار
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه بشكل مستدام الى
مناطق القطاع
كافه